and
seating
we have a list of postponements
so if you're when you're ready
and this will be the this i'll make this
in a form of a motion
to postpone
on the regular agenda
number seven automated pharmacy systems
number eight board of veterinary meth
medicine
administration rule 85
rule 104
rule 105
and
number 85 will also require a waiver
request
and
number 11
the puc municipal and county aggregation
rules
i have a second uh mr chair i just want
to bring to your attention uh 9 c which
is 2294
is also on the list for postponing i'm
sorry i missed that i'll add number 94
okay motion by the chair second by
schmidt
any discussion
all those in favor
aye
questions
um representative tucker could sit for
uh
representative hatch
okay
we need a motion
to
um and before moving on to the consent
items if i could just um advise that
first we addressed the minutes yes well
i was
motion by grace i can buy schmidt to
approve the minute to any discussion
seeing none all those into favor
any opposed
you have
your motion to approve the
in a second by schmidt
any discussion
all those in favor
uh yes mr chair um item five a uh we
have not yet received the response to
the preliminary objection
okay
i had a motion then to postpone that
any discussion
all those in favor
thank you mr chair uh this item is
currently on the regular agenda only
because
the veterinary previous
rule for fees for the veterinary board
had expired
however at the july meeting the oplc had
put forward rules for fees as
was discussed at that particular meeting
and encompassed in those rules
were
the
new fees for the veterinary board it was
in plc
1002.44
since the july meeting those rules have
been adopted they were adopted on august
1st 2022 so there are now rules in
effect for the veterinary board to
collect fees
and that's the only reason that's on the
agenda is i just wanted to bring that to
the committee's attention
to see if they had any questions
regarding that and to also remind the
committee that the oplc represented at
the july meeting that they had not been
collecting fees prior to the enactment
tell us who you are
hello my name is lauren warner i am
and your comment
um i was just here if you had any
questions regarding um whether or not
collecting fees
during that time in which they were
expired
but attorney recorded already noted at
that time we
oplc had not been collecting fees once
the vet rules had expired up until we
started collecting fees again when the
oplc 1002s came into
an effect
okay
do we need to take any action
i
had that on the regular agenda
because of the fee issue but also the
rules themselves are expired so in case
the committee also had any general
questions about the rules being expired
and
what action the board has been taking
with regard to licenses and
so the board has been approving
applications
during the time but has not been
collecting fees as the board did not
have authority to collect the fees but
still had the authority in which to
approve and review applications
um since 2019 when the vet board came
over to oplc we've been working with the
board to draft rules i know we have a
number
of
uh initial proposals and conditional
um
in the currently with uh ols as well as
a few more that will be coming through
so we're working through
updating all of their rules at this time
and you'll have that done
i
think so i apologize i'm not the one
that works on the vet rules i'm covering
someone today but um we should have that
done
by the end of the year i know a number
of them
are going through each board meeting
they're working on rules so
i know we have the 500s if this is the
300s
there are i wouldn't expect it to be
very long before the
the entire um rules are updated
okay veterinary medicine has a long
checkered history
with shell car
so somebody should try a little bit
harder yes and i know oplc has been
working regularly with the board
especially since i've come on in may
okay
any questions
here
so is the executive director in today uh
because i would like to speak with her
about uh
some other issues but i'm i would if she
is in i will discuss with her the
question that the chair has raised with
regard to where we are on this because
um
she is she had a
family
um
conflict this morning so she will be in
later today that's why i'm here
sir
so mr chair this particular rule did
have a conditional approval request and
an amended conditional approval requests
so the committee will just need to vote
on whether to accept those
prior to voting on the rule and you're
good
i am good yes thank you okay need a
motion to approve
move
second
motion by grace second by lang
discussion
all those in favor
and just to be clear mr chair the vote
was on the conditional
approval request and the amended thank
thank you mr chair so with regard to
item
9a on the agenda 2022 41
the agency had submitted a conditional
approval request
the
conditional approval request addressed
the majority of staff comments the only
two remaining issues were
first is a legislative intent comment on
page one
that comment is
that these rules have been expired
for
a little while now since january 1st of
2022 so the committee may have questions
about
uh how the agency has been enforcing
this particular rule
since it's been expired
the second comment is also on page one
it's an edit unclear comment
the initial
proposal had cited to rsa 161 j4 which
laid out the requirements for a standard
disclosure summary the comment asked
that they also include rsa 161 j5 which
has a requirement that the standard
disclosure summary be provided to the
potential resident 24 hours in advance
prior to the resident moving into
the particular
organization's rooming
the comment was misunderstood by the
agency and the agency deleted rsa 161 j4
to replace it with rsa 161 j5
which does address the issue of the
notice however the comment states that
they can put back in rsa
161 j4 to layout the requirements of
what's needed on the standard disclosure
and your new faces so tell us who you
are um i've been here before but hello
my name is nicole valenzuela i am the
administrative rules coordinator at
department of health and human services
hi i'm brian clark i'm a policy
administrator for the bureau of
and your comment your response
with respect to the um edit unclear on
the first page there for uh 605.04a
uh yes correct reading the the note from
ols was misinterpreted as it only
referenced 161 j5 we are going to
include both
reference to j4 and j5 we did include
the language that was recommended by ols
so we will make that that edit and
and regarding whether we've been
enforcing the rule while it's expired we
have not
okay
nothing further
from me
yeah
yes carol
i'm concerned that for three years you
haven't been enforcing a rule because
why do you need it in that case i mean
or why
or how are you managing to run your
i think you're looking at the other one
yeah oh okay this is only this year's
thank you that's a good question
i will reserve my comments for the next
and
um at this time i have no further
comments of
uh committee would like to take up the
voting on this particular conditional
second
motion by gray second by mcguire
discussion
all those in favor
uh yes mr chair so this rule there was
only one comment on page one once again
as a legislative intent comment as this
rule is also expired and this rule has
been expired since november 18th of 2019
so the committee may have questions
about how the agency has been enforcing
this particular rule or if they have
now
tell us about this
uh for the record again nicole
valenzuela rules coordinator for
department of health and human services
i will let brian clark speak to the
expiration
hi uh brian clark bureau of el dorado
adult services uh so what happened here
is
in 2019 when the rule was scheduled to
expire
the department was planning legislation
to change how the
adrd respite care program worked in 2020
and unfortunately
um the rule expired in the interim
and then in 2020 the legislation was set
to we would were planning to re-adopt
the rule in 2020 under the new
legislation that would change the
program however um kovid 19 shifted
priorities both within the department
and presumably within the legislator and
and so
that brings us to today
the legislation
was recently passed
and now we are re-adopting to enact it
um in the interim
uh
we have had a budget allocated to this
program
we have been spending it we have been
contracting
with contract agencies
to run this program and there is a
statute uh rsa 161 f 65 through 70
that's very nice
how many other of your rules
are you requesting specifically for
bureau of of adult services well hhs is
a very large department and it has
people like administrative rules
coordinators and so if you could tell us
for the whole department i'd like to
know because i'm extremely concerned
that you can go for three years without
a statute a rule to run a statutorily
managed program
yeah i mean i couldn't allyson can speak
if she wishes i couldn't tell you an
uh good morning allison radmay
administrator of the administrative
rules unit here for the department of
health and human services
um the department is
i'm sorry
becoming more staffed
and we are individually working with
specific programs to get their rules up
and running uh whichever is expired i
don't have a complete total for you um
but that is a priority of ours
um we're a large agency as you know we
have over 3000 rules
and we're trying really hard to get them
yeah pardon me i think it's ridiculous
that an organization like that can
not know how many of its rules are
expired or expiring and how on earth can
you manage to run run to your operation
without effective rules i don't know how
you can do it
senator whitley thank you mr chair
thanks for taking my question just sort
of on that line um
you know i know that
uh in past
budget years you know there have been
cuts to the department so i'm wondering
if you're aware of you know sort of the
vacancy rate and um i know there were
freezes on hiring and so can you speak
to how those vacancies inability to hire
cuts to your staff have impacted your
ability to look at those expired rules
um so since i've been here um almost
five years now there's only been
one uh sometimes two of us in the unit
um as the speaking for the whole
department i am not sure that is above
bella
thank you mr chair um and i'm it's more
of a comment but if you do need more
staff then i would hope that you would
come you know to the legislature in the
upcoming budget cycle to make sure that
you have the appropriate staff to
to you know fulfill your
care thanks for trying thank you
peter
thank you mr chairman so allison uh
we
we're all cognizant of the fact that the
covet has played havoc with a lot of
things in this country and on the planet
for that matter
but one of the things that
representative mcguire has has just
spoken to
is
the the concern that we all have
is that
you don't know
what you don't know effectively and and
uh so is that that is something that i
think
to the degree that you possibly can get
a handle on
um know what's out there it's kind of
like we never look in that room we don't
know what's in that room and so forth
well
it's it's not obviously
we understand the pandemic has been a
major factor in all this but the bottom
line is
we simply have to get a better handle on
what's out there
including all these
all these expired rules that are
potentially
uh
playing havoc with uh orderly
functioning can have that may i respond
do you agree
um yes we do agree and actually we have
been working on creating a an internal
database of going through every single
rule um it's something that we are
working on and we have created with that
being said
due to the workload that's something
that's being balanced along with for
example opening i've had 55 rules myself
since january so it's just balancing
between prioritizing those rules but we
are building um
a by rule section by section of the
status of everything when this was
brought up to us
many months ago um it's something that
there's a there's a similar effort
happening
administrative roles
for all everybody else
so perhaps they should be working
together to approve this
yes
okay we need a motion to
ocean bigger by grey second by word
any discussion
all those in favor
any
objections
in spite of the lengthy list of
postponements we will carry those over
to the next regular mr chair meeting
i apologize for interrupting i didn't
want to have dhhs leave because i have a
question for them under other business
yes uh yes so what was your question i'm
sorry there's we don't have an attorney
where do we get the other business but i
didn't want to pertain to administrative
rules yes okay go ahead thank you so mr
chair this is that question i sent about
administrative rules and the fact that
um under house bill 1035 we changed the
criteria for vaccination exemption at
schools to remove the notary requirement
and yet under the new form that dhhs put
forward they now ask a bunch of medical
questions in in alignment with asking
parents to acknowledge risk to things
that none of which was in the law that
was passed and so i'm concerned about a
how form was changed without coming
before jalcar and b how the new
conditions apply in three it appears
there's two different forms on the dhhs
website one for child care one for child
care and schools so i'm concerned that a
it didn't come through rules processed
for the form change and for the
information and we haven't seen any
rules around that form
and i just want to have the agency bring
that forward
um so
uh thank you i personally cannot speak
to that at this time i'm gonna take i'm
taking down some notes to bring back to
uh the department and i'm not certain if
allison she's the administrator of the
unit she and i together the unit um this
could be something that she'd been
working on and i'm just not involved in
that but um you said the house bill was
did you say 10 35 house bill 10 35 and
35 they just removed the notary
requirement which so we expected it just
being my kids unvaccinated due to the
fact that they have a religious
exemption period but the new form
says
he's exempt from certain you know he has
you check off which vaccines they are it
makes parents acknowledge risk i think
there's is there is that some statute
right is that yes it's there's part of
it under statute
not the things you're asking for okay so
it goes above and beyond the statute
yeah absolutely okay
um
and you said you saw it for both public
school systems and private child care
right so there's a form i'm on your
website and there's one form that's
that's dated
it was last time i was revised it says
was 5 18 and that's four
certification religious exemption and
child care programs and immunization and
then there's another form you have
that's titled the hampshire child care
school immunization religious exemption
so you have two different four and that
one's dated july of 22.
and so both forms are on your website
one still requires a notary requirement
um and the other one asks for
information that's way beyond the scope
of the change of the law okay
i um beyond school
i will bring this back to allison as
when i get back to the office
and
i will make her aware and have her you
know look and do it what have you and
speak to the attorney who who does work
with immunizations
and do
i'm new to this do you want alison to
sorry sorry representative mcguire yes
oh i'm concerned also that
the department has
no authority to adopt this sort of form
without
going through this process
and if it's in the if it's dated in july
that means we should have seen it last
month and we didn't yes i 100 agree with
you um
i will see what happened i don't know if
uh if a department or an individual for
some reason created a form and posted it
without our knowledge but it's been
brought to our attention
we don't have full control over the
website and who posts things so a unit
could technically do that which isn't
okay if you could make sure that anyone
who posts anything has had it properly
approved that
or
may make the owner of the website know
that because it is very distressing that
random people
can create a form that ha that is a rule
that has the effect of law
and just plop it on your website without
anyone reviewing it yeah
i agree and if i understand it that's
what happened yeah it says each unit
does have an individual who can upload
to the website and that you're correct
of course isn't the proper channel um
it's a bigger issue clearly and i'll
i'll bring it up to those above me to
probably have to speak across the
departments
you know given that
schools will open soon
and
this form which apparently has not been
properly approved
will be in effect
take a recess so that someone could
check right now but it doesn't seem to
me that this form should be
left there
and in force for the beginning of school
which is very very soon i noticed the
other day when i was out campaigning
that one of the towns is opening august
29th
so that must be it's a little later
usually in the north country because of
the lancaster fair but many schools are
opening this month
and so this is a really important thing
i think to take a recess and see whether
we can deal now
with getting that okay we're not going
to try to revamp
their posting system
it's not the posting system it's the
parents are going to have to fill this
out apparently
is that not who is directed towards uh
representative lang i'm just tagging on
i haven't talked with representative
lang in advance so perhaps he could get
a little more information about why he's
concerned so again i the the form is
posted up online and the parents looking
for an exemption form that's the form
they're gonna find um on dhh's website
so and it's a form that's not been
vetted properly and should be taken off
the website
i also want to bring to the committee's
attention that it appears that we do
have an interim rule uh with our office
2022-5
that should be on the september agenda
that
this discussion may
be able to address at that time
okay so we're looking for assurance from
the department today
that
the guilty form has been removed
the jail car staff
and just for clarification uh attorney
ricard
the interim rule that's in place doesn't
cover
representative lang's concerns correct
like it does it's not part of that rule
all i know is that
we currently have a interim rule i've
just been notified by
one of the other staff members that
there's a rule that this
discussion will happen at on the
september agenda i have not personally
looked at the rule so i don't know
what's in there um can you give me that
rule number or the notice number or
either yes it's interim rule 2022 five
okay it's atp something 300 something
i just have that's okay i just have our
internal number that's right um and i
also just wanted to
reiterate um the committee's concerns
that if a form is not approved by jail
carol yes i'd like to
um mention that this
sounds like an
ideal application of the
emergency update to forms
because the law passed you want to have
it before the beginning of school and it
should have been able to be
very quickly implemented
and i'm
would would hope that the department is
aware of that option
uh yes i will can speak to them about
the expedited revision to form process
should that have been
um
if this is something that we can even do
though it sounds like there's concern
that it's above and beyond the scope
regardless
um but yes i will bring this straight to
allison when i get back and speak to the
proper inner channels and then
allison will reach out to ols attorneys
today
okay
okay so with that
we're adjourned
you